in many ways Nazi Zombies are the
perfect enemy it's near impossible to
feel any empathy towards them or guilt
when you plaster their internal organs
against the nearby wall after all one is
a shambling mindless foul entity
propelled by an abhorrent evil and the
other is a walking corpse the
combination of the two creates an
adversary that pretty much any
level-headed player can take pleasure in
dispatching since playing zombie army
for dead war I started thinking about
the origin of the nazi zombie and how
they owe their decaying existence to the
more bizarre cultish beliefs and
conspiracies that surrounded the nazi
party in the 30s and 40s not to mention
the occult implications that have
followed the conversation around them
into the 21st century while it's fun to
fight through virtual worlds filled with
a shambling SS the idea of an undead
ubermensch has existed since as early as
the 1940s and the connection between
dark occultism and the Nazi Party has
existed for decades longer who would
have thought a game focused around
showcasing the internals of ended'
craniums would be so thought-provoking
historian Nicolas goodra Clarke's book
the occult roots of Nazism discusses the
possible links between supposed black
magics as well as the racist a cult
movement of arias ephie including the
far-fetched belief that the German
people were survivors of the lost city
of Atlantis his book also goes on to say
that he found that most of the modern
mythology surrounding that sea occultism
was sensationalized and under researched
it's also important to remember that
claims such as Hitler being possessed by
a demon or that the party was controlled
by an unseen cult creates a scapegoat
for those evil acts committed by evil
people and as fantastical as this
discussion may be any links between the
individuals and actions that plagued our
real world should always be considered
thus evil and that wickedness be it
through the lens of nonfiction or
over-the-top tropes should never be
denied the connection between the occult
and Nazism regardless of how deep that
connection went or as false as it really
is has been a huge springboard for a
wide range of fiction and pop culture
for decades from movies to comic books
to video games from the mutants and
shamblers of the Wolfenstein series to
the boarded up windows of Call of Duty's
NAFTA and totin or more recently the
leftover corpses of Hitler's plan Z in
zombie army 4 dead 1
the first media to connect the
walking-dead with the evil fascist
regime was the 1941 American World War
two b-movie king of the zombies the plot
featured the crashed and stranded
occupants of a u.s. plane a mansion
haunted by zombies and a doctor turned
foreign spy engaging in voodoo rituals
in an effort to extract war intelligence
from a captured us Admiral pretty much
as propaganda cheese as they come if
there's one thing that I wouldn't want
to be twice rhombuses bopparoo the 1960s
saw the release of many more coke B
movies featuring the mindless drones of
reanimated Wehrmacht soldiers the 1966
British science fiction horror the
frozen dead is based around an
unrepentant Nazi scientist stockpiling
frozen German soldiers across Europe in
order to reanimate them when his
superiors deem it necessary only for the
suspended animation to end prematurely
bringing back the soldiers in a state of
the aforementioned zombified Nazi and
while not exactly meeting that
traditional zombie trope the decade also
saw the release of the widely parodied
they saved Hitler's brain everyone's
always in favor of saving Hitler's brain
but when you put it in the body of a
great white shark who's gone too far the
premise of a nazi zombie is hard to
really take seriously it's quite often
betrayed as tongue-in-cheek and as such
takes the edge of any real horror that a
traditional zombie may instill but that
being said this particular beast has
made its way into some bizarre media in
various ways such as the awful shark
enstein when Nazi scientists tried to
experiment with weaponizing dead sharks
there's a premie over the top dead snow
also featuring the Thord undead and the
M I have no idea how to describe it of
course there's a Tomb Raider Nancy
zombie porn parody and of course it has
a mummy trying to raise the Fourth Reich
listen somebody made that movie and I
learned about it while writing the
script so by God you have to know about
it too anyway back to the topic at hand
when you look beyond the nazi zombie
trope that has featured in many a movie
in-game and take into account some of
the more let's say down-to-earth occult
connections hundreds if not thousands of
sources of media Oh some element of
their narrative inspiration
for the fantastical thought that
Blackmagic was an influence to the awful
events of World War two
Indiana Jones draws from the Reich's
obsession with Christian relics like the
spear of destiny or holy Lance objects
they were hoping to use as symbols of
political power themes that are echoed
in the movies where such religious
artifacts are being sought after for a
physical tangible power rather than a
metaphorical one you chose Hellboy the
Wolfenstein series and even Captain
America uses the Nazis connection to the
occult and eccentric Board of Sciences
to either add a different spin to the
big bad or to create a new wrinkle in
their evil and allow for larger feats of
heroism when it comes to thwarting their
efforts one of the games that is most
well-known for Nazi Zombies however is
call of duty world at war world of wars
nazi zombie mode established the formula
for the franchise to follow pitting
players against a horde of the undead
while wielding an ever-growing arsenal
of weapons and power-ups as the game
progressed the popularity of the mode
meant that it would go on to feature in
many future Call of Duty titles but
would lose the Nazi moniker instead
simply become known as the zombies mode
that is until the series would return to
its roots with Call of Duty World War 2
one of the core themes of the
Wolfenstein franchise both old and new
is the blending of the myths of Nazi
occultism technological fringe signs as
well as the unfortunately real awful
human experimentation horrific undead
mutants appeared in a very first
Liechtenstein 3d clad in green with
pistols sticking from their chests
created to be very literal killing
machines part of the plot in the chapter
operation Eisen Faust
follows BJ blaskowitz as destruction of
the Nazi plans to create an undead
mutant army the undead also make an
appearance in 2001 s Return to Castle
Wolfenstein and once more in the form of
shamblers in 2015's prequel to the new
order Wolfenstein the old flood a title
played much more on the occult and
supernatural elements of the series
[Music]
look at that it's raining Nazis
and as if to showcase the range of the
nazi zombie they also appear as one of
the main enemies in South Park stick of
truth their dialogue being made up of
excerpts of Hitler's speeches and of
course most recently the inspiration
behind this feature zombie army for dead
war which continues on the sniper elite
based zombie army trilogy in a world
where hitler unleash plan Z and was
banished to hell but is rotting undead
continue to roam the world of course the
task of emptying their skulls is left to
you now I've been a fan of a Sniper
Elite Series since playing the first on
my PlayStation 2 in 2005 and while
originally apprehensive about the pivot
into the world of a b-movie SK zombie
co-op game I was pleasantly surprised
with a combination of sniper mechanics
x-ray kill cams and the enjoyment of
dispatching nazi zombie hordes with a
certain element of precision a nazi
zombie antagonist creates a backdrop
that allows for a much more obscure in
arcane game world while also feeling
like a somewhat familiar setting a
mindless horde is a common theme when it
comes to four player co-op titles be
they left it at vermintide or zombie
army but each title adds its own wrinkle
to the formula most recently that comes
in the form of zombie snipers undead
sharks electric suppressors and a
plethora of b-movie tropes and Easter
eggs that connect the game to its cult
horror roots now if you have some squad
mates to team up with I can heartily
recommend trying out the latest entry in
all things nazi zombie dispatching but
considering these Gestapo ghouls have
been in our media for around 80 years
now and i think they're going to go away
anytime soon so with that being said we
may as well enjoy ridding our virtual
worlds of the one enemy that really is a
delight to destroy
[Music]